je plane sur et le jeu tourne comme un
retour comme un buzz sur youtube
j'ai escaladé tour on n'a pas donné de
voix je communique quand sous titré mais
des fois fait les onomatopées
[Musique]
on est aujourd'hui sur le tournage de
mon nouveau clip pour sa part le zelda
notamment l'opus
donc
le problème majeur jeu j'ai des cheveux
dans la bouche et dans le visage et
sakassou mon visage quoi je pourrais
être n'importe qui en dessous ça
pourrait être squeeze serait pareil
salut salut spock mes claques pour spock
ça veut dire que sur les connaît pas
elle da soit mon costume est normal fait
quoi je stoppe l'espace si j'arrive
[Musique]
quelqu'un mercou l'entrejambe c'est très
mal les ans le malaise était de kato
talent bah ouais voilà à toit du court
artisan de métier la lourdeur de l'homme
débâcle ailleurs pas hyper hype
impressionnant c'est vrai je veux pas de
blessés c'est pour ça que je vais
doucement je parle je m'appelle pas elle
tarde pas
non ils ne connaissent même pas
je serais content de tourner dans
tonnage de norman dans le monde grande
chaîne youtube sur la rue aussi loin
c'est moi merde je dis là le passage
pennel tue sa mère je veux le faire pour
moi jen c'est l'un des meilleurs
comédiens de france j'ai fait dans son
chariot
donc j'ai le droit de chanter non
seulement jamais nous savourons gérant
quelques colis considéré comme suspect
revienne orange est superbe alors sa
jumelle
[Musique]
ça c'est les fameuses onomatopées
deligne clp théâtre et constatent un
mois j'ai perdu un pari et des jeux de
l'oie faire le faux link donc enfiler
cette magnifique noir et quand je
t'appelle tu es dans son élan à sa
question de chanter allez c'est parti
je suis un tendon bleus cuisine comme un
chef fait des plats douteuses pour
masterchef j'te mais quoi pour ceux qui
connaissent le jeu ça c'est vraiment le
chaudron qu'on utilise quand on veut
faire de la cuisine quand on voit ce que
pareil les plats ça reste pas que
totalement le mons où je n'ai pas
totalement la dimension de mon estomac
voilà on harcèle décor tout est
absolument parfait pour faire la scène
de zelda
sauf un détail près il ya le pêcheur ne
veut pas aller pêcher cinq mètres plus
loin c'est vraiment sous projets il faut
prendre la truite cas dans le champ
gilbert le pêcheur d'abord alors ça
c'est intéressant ça c'est l'arbre
officiel du jeu
même les feuilles sont authentiques
c'est génial ouais là demain demain
jeudi à 14 h et maternelle charles kao
je passe mes appels
ma peau de balle touchée avant de venir
écrevisses tout rose alors que tout le
monde est au soleil avec moi je suis en
quête perpétuelle donc je fais tout seul
sous cet arbuste en langage mais survolé
hyrule mais bon
alors j'attends vers un peu mécanique
[Musique]
je veux vraiment
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci à tous d'avoir regardé ce making
of voilà trou qui fait perçu éclipse
était vraiment un énorme qui motive
d'apprécier mettez un petit poucet les
voir la vidéo si vous l'avez pas déjà vu
et puis lorsque vous bientôt pour une
prochaine vidéo
moi je vais prendre cette photo tarina
j'ai gardé mes biens d'équipement pouces
bleus c'est la très fort c'est la trique
ouais abonne toi tout bleu c'est la
triforce
c'est la triforce ouais abonne toi
pouces bleus c'est la triforce c'est la
triforce ouais abonne toi blouse bleue
c'est la triforce
c'est la triforce ouais abonne toi